anoche fue otra de las jornadas en las
que las fuerzas rusas lanzaron una Nueva
Ola de misiles crucero y drones
kamikazes chajín de fabricación iraní
contra Ucrania según el jefe máximo de
las fuerzas militares ucranianas 18
misiles cruceros fueron lanzados contra
el país 15 de ellos fueron interceptados
y estamos en una de esas posiciones que
tienen como tarea evitar que esos
misiles lleguen a su destino estamos en
la provincia de donest esta es una
posición donde tienen sistema de defensa
antiaéreo portátil para misiles Ellos
dicen que anoche aquí vieron cruzar tres
misiles dos de ellos cayeron una
población no muy lejos aunque no tienen
información o no la pueden dar de lo que
sucedió con esos misiles otro aún más
lejos posiblemente la población de Pablo
gratis que fue la más atacada no
solamente la noche de ayer Sino en horas
anteriores
es que ellos aseguran que en los últimos
días las fuerzas rusas han incrementado
este número de ataques aéreos Buscando
cómo atacar esas bases y lugares donde
los ucranianos guardan sus armas y sus
municiones que utilizarán en esa
contraofensiva que está planeada para
los próximos días cuando el clima se
mejore las carreteras para llegar hasta
aquí están llenas de barro hoy ha estado
lloviendo en la mañana y aquí mismo nos
decían que este tipo de armas de
antidefes portátiles antidefensa no
funcionan en este tipo de clima porque
ni siquiera cuando está nublado o cuando
está lluvioso porque no son Realmente
efectivas y en ese momento tiene que
entrar a funcionar otro sistema de
defensas antimisiles lo que hace aún más
complicado sin embargo también dicen que
los rusos cuando está lloviendo y hace
este tipo de clima al menos evitan
mandar mayor número de naves y
especialmente de helicópteros